good morning strange loop uh everyone
awake
ready to talk about some neat ocean
drones
uh
real fast i just want to echo what aj
said uh during the opening keynote uh
you know and just give a huge shout out
to alex and all the strange strange loop
crew um i first attended here
in 2019 and loved it so much that i
decided to come back as a presenter so i
hope that's a testament to just what a
cool event this is so
huge out to them and thanks for having
me
all right right so my name is todd
bellmer
this is my twitter handle in case any of
you want to see me complain at brands
about their terrible products uh or
occasionally make the bad programming
joke um and well what do i do uh i was
an early engineer at sale drone that
built the initial incarnations of the
systems we're going to talk about today
today i manage our fleet operations
software team which is a team
responsible for not only these systems
but a number of other critical
components of the sale drone
stack and uh just company
and so you might be asking yourself well
gee todd what is sail drone uh and i
would respond with i'm happy that you
asked um
we build sailboats that are drones
thank you for coming my todd talk
this is so dumb
all right in all seriousness sail drone
builds and operates a fleet of uncrewed
surface vehicles or usvs the the bulk of
the fleet is composed of
vessels that we call explorers
and they feature a trick aerodynamic
wing this wing allows the explorers to
sail being propelled by by wind but they
can also be propelled by ocean currents
as well
one of the things people are most
surprised about when we talk about these
things is just how big these these
vehicles actually are there are no toys
it's not the size of that quadcopter i
showed you just a moment ago these
things are 23 feet long they're pretty
large
uh power for the onboard systems is
provided by banks of onboard batteries
and these batteries can be charged by
solar panels on the wing and hole
and additionally they can be charged
with devices called hydrogenerators
which convert the kinetic energy of the
drone moving through the water into
electricity that we can store in the
batteries
those batteries are used to power the
multitude of different payloads we run
on board the drones these vehicles are
cramped full of sensors that can collect
a variety of atmospheric data so things
like wind speed ambient temperature
humidity
things of that nature
ocean surface data so things like
current speed or sorry wave height water
temperature salinity etc and then
finally subsurface data so current speed
at a given depth temperature at a given
depth bathymetric measurements and fish
stock tracking
we actually regularly work with
different fisheries that are interested
in tracking their fish stocks so we can
know whether we are fishing sustainably
or not that's a pretty common mission
that we opt that we run
sale drone owns and operates the fleet
of vehicles and our mission capability
is leased to our clients with both
configured in particular ways depending
on a given client's mission parameters
and goals
some of our notable clients include
organizations such as the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
nasa
and their european australian and
japanese counterparts
still drones also have the ability to
monitor sensitive protected marine
habitats as many of you may know illegal
fishing is a scourge of the oceans that
devastates coastal communities and
marine ecosystems
we at cell drone have developed a
machine learning-based camera system
that's capable of detecting vessels
within a drone's visual range
this technology can be used for a
variety of purposes marine sanctuary
enforcement being one of them but
they're also defense and law enforcement
applications for this technology as well
the upshot is that sales drones can
perform their science missions while as
a bonus keeping watch for illegal
activity in areas where fishing or other
activities have been restricted
cell drones are also capable of
performing bathymetric surveys so if
that sounds like a nonsense phrase
it's just a fancy way of saying seafloor
mapping
as many of you may know we know more
about the
the surface of mars and we know about
the bottom of our own oceans
and you might ask well todd what's the
big deal it's it's all underwater
anyways
the big deal is that bathymetry data
lays the foundation to many other
aspects of ocean science so safety of
navigation cable laying
wind farm planning discovery of natural
resources and protection of fragile
ecosystems
by understanding the sea floor we can
bolster our understanding of these other
areas by providing detailed maps that
allow researchers to determine where
they want to look for potential new
discoveries
to support this mission we've built
another class of drone that we call
surveyor surveyor is a 72 foot behemoth
that has multiple commercial grade echo
sounders or sonars in the keel
it became operational earlier this year
and in fact the image from the previous
slide was composed from data that we
collected on our maiden voyage from san
francisco to hawaii and back
on that same voyage surveyor also
encountered a previously unknown sea
hill uh which is smaller than a c mount
but will take credit for a new discovery
nonetheless
to perform the missions that any of our
vessels are capable of not just surveyor
you'd historically need a large crude
vessel of some sort that needs to go out
in the middle of the ocean for months on
end while it transects back and forth or
holds stations somewhere with dozens of
people on board
sale drones are capable of performing
these same types of missions for a
fraction of the cost a fraction of the
environmental impact and that's all
without anyone ever needing to leave the
shore
all of our vehicles are capable of long
endurance missions they operate hundreds
if not thousands of miles
from shore for months on end
drones sail a route autonomously that's
chosen by human operators
i don't know how many of you know
anything about sailing
but autonomous sailing is a pretty
sophisticated system that we needed to
build the drones need to know how to how
and when to perform certain maneuvers
like tacking and jibing uh all without a
human in the loop
the drones are capable of operating in
extreme conditions regularly operating
in places like the arctic and southern
oceans
and if you have we're following the news
uh also in the middle of an in the eye
of a category four hurricane uh this was
released yesterday and so why would we
want to huck drones right in the middle
of a hurricane um well if you've seen
the movie twister that might give you a
good idea
of why uh there's there's no substitute
for collecting in-situ data at the
ground level in order to augment our
understanding of how these systems
operate so what you're seeing on the
left here is um in this video is um wind
speed as shown in our mission management
software and on the right you see the
video taken from onboard that same drone
um inside the eye of the hurricane and
thankfully it stopped because that makes
me a little seasick on land
so going back to this slide uh the image
on the slide is a visualization of the
route taken by one of our drones in 2019
that voyage marked the first successful
autonomous circumnavigation of
antarctica and some of this data set
from that mission is public and if
you're interested you can find that at
data.saledrone.com
but this was a long endurance mission
this took you know the better part of
six months
and the southern ocean is one of the
most inhospitable places in the in the
world that's the ocean that surrounds
antarctica um and it's certainly home to
some of the roughest seas
so
given the distance from shore the
duration of these missions and the
exotic locales that our drones operate
in
how do we manage their health and safety
well in the early days we'd make use of
manually checking data that we plotted
in our mission management software
and
while the drones are at sea they record
all manner of scientific data and
telemetry and so we send back low
low resolution data that's of the on the
order of one minute or longer typically
that's sent back in near real time over
satellite communications higher
resolution data than that we store
onboard the drones until they come back
to port so that we can offload it once
they once they've returned home
and this approach worked okay with just
a few drones on the water that don't
move very quickly we just have one or
two people that would stare at these
graphs for hours on end and just wait
for something abnormal to happen
but this obviously doesn't scale very
well when you have dozens of drones
operating at any given time so how do
you solve the problem of monitoring many
drones operating in many different
locales in many different environments
with many different configurations
well we're at a software conference so
if you guess you automate it then i'm
gonna give you a gold star
enter sonar a stream processing engine
for telemetry uh sonar was a way more
clever name for this by the way before
we started doing a lot of work in the
bathymetry space where we're using
actual sonars to take measurements of
things but i digress
sonar consumes real-time telemetry from
jones and performs various analyses on
it it highlights any potential issues
alerts fleet operators or engineers and
handles the the issue management life
cycle
sonar will wait to receive new data from
drones that corrects a failure condition
and then closes out issues appropriately
to summarize it's a it's just a
monitoring and alerting system for
drones
so let's talk about the technical bits
here uh moving in the clockwise
direction uh sonar is written in
typescript and runs in on node.js
it uses redis heavily we actually
maintain a hot cache of time series data
inside this hot cache so that sonar
doesn't need to have any external
dependencies on our primary time series
store this keeps it isolated in the
event of upstream issues with with those
services so that we have a mission
critical service that can always run and
is not dependent on anything
else we use postgres as our primary
persistent data store for things that we
need to store other than time series
data
we use aws sqs for
for queuing drone telemetry it's running
on kubernetes and docker
and you might note there's nothing
terribly exotic here these are all
pretty standard well understood
technologies
and that's the power of this system in
my opinion it enables new engineers to
come in and make new additions very
quickly
even if they don't understand the the
system entirely um using tools and tools
and languages and systems that they're
likely already familiar with from
previous experience
so sonar consists of a number of
different pieces of logic we call checks
and these checks form the basis of the
monitoring system in sonar and contain
the core logic for executing analysis on
different pieces of data
so check types include simple
event-driven checks like a threshold
check to make sure that data is under or
over some min or max value
a simple comparison check like equality
or inequality to make sure that
something like a sensor has turned on or
off when we expect it to have been in
rate of change checks we can perform a
simple statistical analysis on time
series data to see whether the set of
values is increasing or decreasing too
rapidly or too slowly we might use this
for something like inspecting the state
of batteries to make sure that the state
of the state of charge isn't uh
degrading too quickly or too slowly
uh there are more complicated
event-driven checks that we use for
vehicle navigation specifically checking
to see if a vehicle is out of its
quarter or not
when we send a route to a drone we
typically provide it with
a boundary radius that provides a
corridor that the drone can sail in as
attacks and back and forth trying to
sail the route
and you know if that drone leaves that
leaves that boundary for some reason we
want to know about that it could be
indicative of problems on the vehicle or
just poor conditions
uh these types of checks also include
other types of geo-fencing checks that
ensure a drone either stays in a given
area or doesn't stray into another
and if a drone steps outside of his
corridor or his geofence it could be
indicative of
light wind or current so it's important
for us to let operators know if we are
just simply unable to sail in those
current conditions
we have a class of check called
downstream checks we'll come back to
those in a moment
and finally we have schedule checks all
these checks are predominantly event
driven meaning that they're predicated
on the system having received some
telemetry from a drone
but if we don't receive any any data
from a drone that's also a problem right
so we have different checks that can
operate on a cron to check things like
whether we've received any data from a
drone and alert if that is if we haven't
seen anything from a drone in a given
time period
all right so i promise we get back to
downstream checks downstream checks are
other logical checks that are written
and executed outside of the core sonar
service
why might we want that
sometimes we might want to take
advantage of a library that's not
available in javascript or a developer
from another team might not know much
typescript but they can crank something
out in python really fast
or we might want to do some sort of
analysis on time series data going back
further than what sonar's hot cache can
provide so we'll call out to our actual
time series data store
there are multitude of reasons that you
might want to do this and take advantage
of this system so enabling developers to
spin up isolated checks and configure
sonar to trigger them has enabled
developers to quickly and easily add new
functionality to our alerting systems
all without the need to touch the core
service at all unless they want to
so how does it work the downstream check
exposes a web hook or a message queue
that sonar can use to delegate check
execution
hitting that web hook or dropping a
message on the queue triggers the
downstream check and it performs this
analysis
uh sonar will sometimes send data to
that check that the check will perform
its analysis on or that check may call
out to some other system or service to
get the data it needs to perform its
analysis
once the check is complete it calls back
to the main sonar service to report the
result of its execution
if the check is executed successfully
everything everything is good we move on
with life
but if the check has failed sonar will
handle the issue management lifecycle as
it normally would for any other type of
check
with this in mind sonar isn't just a
simple monitoring and alerting service
it's an entire monitoring and alerting
ecosystem that we've built
we've added a number of different check
types this ecosystem using this
methodology including checks that
determine if a drone is too close to
shore that's a check that's a function
that's written in go that operates
entirely outside of the out of the core
service
we might want to determine whether a
sensor has stopped working properly
that's another function that's written
in python
all these things can execute outside the
main sonar service
in languages of a developer's choice
without them needing to
needing a touch sonar at all
all right so here's an abridged look at
how sonar checks operate and before i
dive into it it's worth just mentioning
that the same set of checks might not
apply to all drones or even to the same
drone for a different message it
receives um it's this is indicative of a
specific message received uh received
from a drone at a specific time and the
content of that message can vary from
transmission to transmission
so
in the beginning there is a message
queue and it is good
uh this queue is responsible for
shuttling telemetry data from drones
back into sonar
sonar picks up the message and puts it
through them through a message handler
inside of itself
this message handler checks to make sure
that the data we've received is indeed
something sonar actually cares about
otherwise we just discard it immediately
it then checks to see what vehicle data
what vehicle the data
has been received for and whether checks
are enabled for that vehicle
if the vehicle is set up to have checks
performed the message handler then pulls
out all the variables in that message
there can be a number of them
determines which checks need to be run
based on the
vehicle and
the variables that we've pulled out and
then finally executes all of those
checks
uh and so that's what you see in the in
the right hand column there
and in the case that a downstream check
needs to be performed sonar calls out to
that check the check executes and then
it reports its results back to sonar
um so finally in that upper left-hand
corner we have one of our scheduled
checks just executing all on its own in
isolation checking to see whether we've
received any messages from a drone or
not
so in the previous slide we looked at
how logical checks get executed inside
of sonar but how do we map individual
pieces of telemetry to different logical
check types
well we store that check configuration
inside of sonar's database that that
postgres instance that i mentioned
earlier
this configuration is responsible for
tying an individual telemetry element to
a specific logical check and is selected
when we receive relevant telemetry from
a drone
by default all checks execute at a
global level but they can be overwritten
on a vehicle by vehicle basis
so in this example we have here in this
form
uh we're configuring a threshold check
for a drone's baseboard temperature and
if a drone's baseboard temperature gets
too hot or too cold
its performance could be impacted in all
sorts of bad ways or something worse
could happen so we want to know when we
approaching when we want to know when
it's approaching its thermal limits
you can see that we've configured a min
and max value for the check that for the
check to execute against and in this
case it's temperatures in degrees
celsius
we can specify a failure message that
will show up in the issue description
should the check fail
and you can see that there are some
variables in it these these messages can
be dynamically uh constructed with
relevant information to fleet operators
or engineers
uh we can additionally uh specify a url
uri for a playbook that will show up in
the incident description
should the check fail
this documentation is super useful for
our mission managers or other engineers
to potentially quickly identify and
resolve common issues so folks don't
need to unravel what a given incident
message means
or have muscle memory from a previous
time that they that they had to resolve
that issue
they just can reference the
documentation and they're good to go
our drones have different operation
modes that have different devices
powered and configured based on what
mode the vehicle is in so we can provide
overrides based on the specific
operation mode of a drone is in so
we might you know want to check for the
power state of a certain sensor in one
mode and don't care about it at all in a
different mode
similarly we can specify what vehicle
generation we want a given check to
apply to and this allows us to create
different checks for surveyor class
vehicles for explorer class vehicles or
in the case that it's blank like it is
here it just executes on all class of
vehicle
we can optionally
set up allowed sequential failures which
tell a check that it needs to fail a
certain number of times before we
actually trigger an incident and
why would we want this wouldn't we want
to know when anything is failing
well you know we deal with hardware that
doesn't always behave the way that we
think it should in software land um a
single failure triggered by a specific
hardware quirk isn't always enough to
raise the alarm but sequential failures
should be
so we allow engineers or mission
managers to make their own calls
on how and when we alert for particular
issues
additionally all checks have a severity
level associated with them and those
severity levels can be staggered so uh
in this instance we're configuring a
medium severity alert for um for
baseboard temperature but in the event
that we wanted to have staggered alerts
for you want to trigger a warning level
when it exceeds some threshold but then
you want to trigger a page when it
exceeds a different one you can set the
various severity levels there and have
them
kind of kind of stagger them that way
certain drones have redundant baseboards
so target cpu in this form simply
differentiates between which baseboards
telemetry we should use to execute a
check on
in this case we're just executing
against both computers
the period of day setting allows us to
specify whether we want to check to
execute during daylight night time or or
both times um as you can imagine
payloads and power states could be
drafted drastically different during
night time versus daytime when we're not
generating any solar power
so it doesn't make sense to necessarily
run the same checks uh at night as we
would during the day so we can we can
hone in on that a little bit
this the setting allows us to override
checks to account for those differences
and finally we can specify a number of
pager duty settings though these only
applied as high severity checks and in
the case that a check should trigger a
pagerduty alert we allow the check to
specify which excuse me which group it
should alert so uh we have a number of
different groups here some of which go
to our mission managers and some of
which go to software engineers based on
the context of
what we're checking and what and what
check
and so as you can see we've built a
number of knobs that we can tweak on on
each check which allows a great deal of
flexibility when creating and modifying
check configurations
so what happens if a check fails and
that event we create what we call an
incident incidents persist until sonar
receives data from a drone that clears
the failure condition in a subsequent
check run
incidents appear in our internal tools
for easy tracking and we'll get
broadcast and drone specific slack
channels
slack is actually a really handy tool
here and i mean for your purposes it
could be any chat application but we use
slack and we practice a form of chat ops
here rallying folks around issues that
require collaboration to resolve in a
semi-public channel that other people
can can participate in and this has the
added benefit of allowing folks not
directly involved in the mitigation
process to learn through osmosis as the
folks that are working on it uh work
through the issues in real time and in
that semi-public forum it allows people
to you know that aren't directly
involved in the process to really
understand what the crux of the issue is
and how they might solve it if they're
in their shoes in the future
finally incidents can also trigger pages
via pagerduty as we as we mentioned a
moment ago
using the example of the baseboard
temperature check from the previous
slide we see that same check failing in
both the ui on the top and in a slack
message at the bottom there
sonar has a rest api and so while sonar
is not primarily a web service we did
bolt one of those onto it
this api is super handy it allows us to
do a number of a number of things namely
performing crud operations on check
configurations from our internal tools
it allows
read operations on incidents for viewing
uh and visualization in those same tools
and those downstream checks we're so
fond of the rest api there provides a
callback web hook that those downstream
checks can then send their check results
back to
so let's try it all together using our
baseboard temperature check example
uh a drone will send telemetry about a
space where temperature back to sail
drone systems in this case the baseboard
is overheating so
we you know we'll see that in the
telemetry that we receive from it
the data will eventually work its way
into sonar after it enters our systems
sonar detects the baseboard temperature
variable and the telemetry selects the
appropriate checks and it's worth
mentioning that there can be multiple
checks for a single variable
uh and then executes them and then
executes them
uh the threshold check we've configured
fails triggering an incident that
incident sends a message to a slack
channel appears in our web uis and pages
an on-call mission manager
to investigate the issue
sales run personnel work to get the
issue under control potentially
escalating it to internal teams to
figure out what the core issue is they
resolve the underlying issue
on the drone and baseboard temperature
drops back down the drone will send a
new set of telemetry with data that
indicates the issue is resolved sonar
will then receive that telemetry re-run
its checks and closes the open incident
as the issue is no longer occurring
okay so how about some additional
non-trivial examples of how this system
is important to us
for one we can use this system for power
alerting so suppose a drone isn't
generating enough solar power because
it's cloudy out it's a real issue we can
alert a pilot so they can decide which
non-critical payloads to turn down or
turn off so we don't completely drain
our batteries in this scenario
we can also use the system for alerting
on payload status when performing
bathymetric surveys with surveyor for
instance we'll frequently need to cast a
sound velocity profiler device off of
the vehicle this device allows us to
collect data about how sound moves in
different areas of the ocean so that we
can use it to calibrate
the echo sounders on the vehicle to make
sure that we are returning the most
appropriate and accurate data about the
c4 as possible
the data retrieved by this device uh can
you know like i said it really enable
if we don't get it if we don't get it
right then it'll really mess up our
measurements so it's important that we
get it so
making sure that that device wakes up
gets cast
takes its measurement and then goes back
to sleep when it's all done is actually
really important so we can use the
system to check for things like that
finally we can use the system for
alerting as part of our drone readiness
process
and as you can imagine there's a whole
phase of drone construction between when
a drone is fully mechanically and
electrically assembled
and when it can actually be put on the
water and this phase includes the
performance of tasks like installing
software installing firmware checking
out sensor payloads
validating data looks like it's in
reasonable ranges and things like that
we call this phase our readiness phase
and sonar plays an important part in it
for instance we frequently ship our
drones to far-off locales for deployment
so they don't have to sail all the way
to their mission sites
when a drone is put in a shipping
container will be deemed 100 operational
buyer by our staff and ready for
deployment
but perhaps in transit a sensor got
jostled loose
or broken and in that case when the
drone is reassembled and brought online
at its remote deployment site sonar will
alert us to the problem and allow us to
address the issue before the drone is
even deployed
all right so how about some numbers
we have over 900 checks configured for
over 350 different variables and we've
run these checks over 100 million times
there are there have been thousands of
issues resolved over the course of
hundreds of drone missions
so that's cool and all but so what uh
the upshot is the system has had some
real tangible benefits for us it allows
mission managers to simultaneously
manage multiple drones without needing
to stare at mind-numbing data and graphs
for hours on end
it's
also freed up those same mission
managers to focus on other aspects of
their roles like managing the
relationship with and the needs of our
science partners
it's alerted us to potential issues with
drones while they're still in the
factory averting problems while they're
while we're at sea
it gives us extensible and flexible
management of checks in the cloud
instead of on vehicle allowing us to
adjust checks on the fly and without
needing to push anything new to the
vehicles themselves and you know over
the year updates are a capability that
we have but they're hard to do and we
prefer to be safe and manage those in
the cloud where possible and that's
exactly what this system
enables
and finally sonar has given us valuable
and measurable insights in the strengths
and weaknesses in our systems and
designs and it's allowed us to really
improve and iterate upon those over time
has played a really instrumental part in
in that phase of our development
so
sale drone is successful and growing but
as we've grown we've needed to create
new solutions to help us scale so if
these types of problems are interesting
to you
we're hiring
and there are actually three of us here
this this week
so if you have questions about sale
drone or interested in talking more
about that then please come
come
seek us out and with that i should have
a few minutes for
questions yeah they're not small so the
question was how are we adhering to uh
you know basic navigation laws and
obstacle avoidance correct
yeah so
um
our pilots are really are really good at
that and in our piloting software which
is also pretty sophisticated i didn't
show any screenshots of it but we have a
sophisticated piloting system that
allows our drone operators to see where
obstacles are using uh you know publicly
available charts
um and so they take those different
obstacles into account
when piloting the drones we also get
real-time ais data in our systems that's
automatic identification
identification system uh data that are
basically transponders for ships
so we can use we can use those to factor
in navigating around uh other vessels uh
while we're in crowded lanes
does that answer your question
sure
the question is what's the biggest
takeaway technical or non-technical
yeah if we're going to do it again would
we do something different
i'm not certain to be honest with you
i think we're pretty happy with the
system overall it has really like i said
enabled us to have an entirely new class
of capabilities on the drones that
wouldn't have been
wouldn't have been available beforehand
there's possible that there might have
been some other technical choices we
would have made
you know given where we're at now and we
may revisit those
but for where we were at the time when
we first created this system it was
exactly what we needed
so the question is uh how do we do
version management for different types
of drones and um for different types of
missions is that correct yeah so we have
a we have a release uh a software
release process that we abide by and a
release candidate process and and all of
that so we perform c trials with the
drones before they're before you prepare
to put them out on actual customer
missions
and that is really the validation
process for for that does that answer
your question great
question is this capsizing a problem for
the sale drones um no not not really um
they have about you know uh
a lot of lead in their keels that
prevents them from uh overturning or um
capsizing so no not not really a problem
for them
sure so the question is if i understood
you correctly is um why did we build our
own time series database uh when there
are so many uh different uh options
available um it partially has um
a bit to do with the shape of our data
but you know we we've we've also are in
the process of completely reworking that
to use more commercially available
systems so i don't think i can get
more uh detailed than that but um yeah i
hope that answers your question
the yeah sure the question is what's our
process for adding a new check and
tuning it and deciding whether it's a
good check
the process is really we identify a need
for a check
and we just go ahead and create that
check whether it's
you know depending on what we're trying
to check it'll be one of those logical
check types um and you know we probably
start kind of on the conservative side
in terms of what we're trying to check
and then we adjust really if it's just
becoming too noisy or you know someone
with more knowledge about what we're
actually checking there comes in and
says this was totally arbitrary why'd
you do it like that um so that's that's
really the process is that does that
answer your question
okay
yeah the question was um uh about
pagerduty and whether there any other
kind of incident response type tools
that we've that we've looped into this
process um no what what you see in the
presentation is is what we've got it's
you know primarily slack web uis and
pagerduty where where necessary
what can we do to solve problems when we
get paged
yeah so i mean it
it really depends on what the actual
issue is
you know we have remote debugging
capabilities that we can use to kind of
inspect what's happening on the drone um
and in in that case it really depends on
what the underlying issue is um when
we're in the shop we have a little more
latitude for that but again it's it's
highly contextual
yeah i mean if so sorry the question is
um if the boat just stopped sending us
telemetry and there's you know no
remediation process for that what do we
do
um
yeah i mean at that point we'd be kind
of hosed if that if that happened uh
um you know thankfully that hasn't so
yeah
any other questions
great okay well thank you so much
everyone it was a pleasure
[Music]
you